al ateísmo porque esta semana se llevó a
cabo la time lic esto con su parada en
dos allí el granadino anderson peters
logró convertirse en el protagonista de
este evento en la disciplina del
lanzamiento de jabalina el más
importante lo que está consiguiendo este
atleta y sobre todo muy cerca del
campeonato del mundo de noche sin sí y
además es importante porque él regresa
al escenario donde ganó el título
mundial en 2019 recordemos él fue
campeón en doha en 2019 y en esta
oportunidad rompió tres veces su marca
personal y apareció con una marca de 88
96 en su primer lanzamiento luego estuvo
bastante retado por el chaco que quedó
en segundo lugar hizo un 90 19 y
finalmente en el último intento aparece
este 93 0 7 que además es récord de la
confederación norte centroamericana y
del caribe un atleta que no se vio bien
en en tokio pero que parece estar
regresando en una jornada que además fue
muy
e inestable las condiciones porque hubo
un ventarrón enorme un vendaval que
incluso obligó a disputar la garrocha al
día siguiente con el estadio el techo
retráctil del estadio cerrado porque no
se pudo hacer en esta ocasión ahora
pasemos al salto de altura donde también
el surcoreano jung woo parece que está
siendo mayor consistente dentro de esto
y deja de ser sorpresa las actitudes o
las actividades que venía desarrollando
y los premios que venía logrando pues si
él fue digamos la gran sorpresa de los
juegos olímpicos cuando ganó la medalla
de bronce
este este atleta coreano wu saunier y
luego ya estaba digamos más cimentado
cuando llegó el mundial bajo techo pero
recordemos que en el mundial bajo techo
no estuvo muchas essa barshim estuvo un
marco tan ver y que no estuvo en su
mejor forma deportiva en esta
oportunidad se encontraron los dos de
nuevo los que compartieron el oro del
salto alto en tokio 2020 quedó segundo
bar sin pero el coreano logra superarlo
como tú lo mencionas deja de convertirse
en una sorpresa y pasa a ser digamos el
hombre estable de las primeras
posiciones en el salto alto ahora me
gustaría pasar a la pista porque está el
caso de frank sin ni un saba un atleta
que prácticamente está haciendo un
proceso de transición y consigue una
buena marca dentro de la carrera de los
3000 metros y un muy buen resultado creo
que es muy interesante el caso de
francisco en saba porque ella es una de
las cuatro atletas junto con caster
semenya de sudáfrica dos cosas de uganda
y margaret huambo y de kenia que fueron
perjudicadas por él lo que se llamó en
su momento el reglamento y para
andrógenos mo que ahora pasó a ser el
reglamento de desarrollo sexual
diferente que es digamos la serie de
reglas para normar la participación de
estas atletas que tienen
esta condición de intersexualidad como
es el caso de ellas 4 la prueba de los
800 que era donde ellas se desarrollaban
se desempeñaban originalmente es una
prueba de resistencia a la velocidad y
ese es precisamente el escenario en el
que más se puede sacar ventaja de ese
desarrollo diferente que ellas tienen
con respecto a otras atletas y por eso
se les ordena subir de distancia y la
única que tomó el reto fue ella y vemos
los resultados además ganándole a la
campeona mundial la campeona olímpica de
1500 que estaba en esa prueba faith
kipyegon muchísimas gracias por
ofrecernos este amplio análisis a lo
largo de la jornada tanto en tenis como
en atletismo un placer